[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen in
deutschland beim jahr kommando wird
wieder gern bei dem jagdverband anpassen
also keine namen
herzlich willkommen ich habe noch viel
vor
wer auf sie zu
[Musik]
ihr habt ein ganz spezielles motto petra
was heißt es übersetzt
er ist niemals zurück soll eigentlich
symbolisieren dass wenn es einen auftrag
gibt dann ist es auftrag unter allen
umständen durchzuführen was genau ist
eine aufgabe spezial software und fairen
spiel unternehmen evakuierungen vor
österreichischen staatsbürgern aus
diesen räumen wir haben spezialisten im
alpinen gelände genauso wie wir
spezialisten haben die sich in
verschiedenen klimatischen bedingungen
müssten wir uns weiter bewegt aber auch
ist gefangenen geiselbefreiung in und
ausland wie lange auch die ausbildung
gesamte bis ganz fertig sein dauert die
ausbildung drei jahre plus eine
fordernde aufgabe den rhein übergeben
zur nächsten station hallo wir wollten
eben unser training beginnen oder kommen
später wieder ganz im gegenteil wir
wollen nicht einladen mitzumachen wir
hoffen so bleibt also du siehst hier
unsere trainingsanlage wir trainieren
wollen die funktionale fitness und dazu
kommt noch das will einst ausrüstung und
trainieren
deswegen will ich auch eine kugel
schutzweste vorbereitet haben was
wichtig acht kilogramm 818 ist genau
diese station seit geht um eine ganz
einfache sache
[Musik]
du musst es bei der kamera wirklich auf
highspeed schalten
[Musik]
bisher gehen weiter zur zweiten station
12 9 10 nach nächster zeit kommen
sie kommen zur dritten station
[Musik]
jawohl wir könnten mal laufen dann
kommen wieder
[Musik]
so an die linie und los ja mal auf
meiner höhe sehr gut reparieren
die kältewelle die gefällt unser ganzes
leben so herrlich es schaffen dass sich
ihre
robert becker alle das heißt du bist
bereit bei uns du machst weiter mit ich
sollte vielleicht nehmen zunächst
ausgeladen
[Musik]
das schneller land mit nur 58 sehr gut
funktioniert braucht er jetzt gehen wir
zum black hawk doch manchmal darüber
dass truppen das ist ein abseilen aus
dem hubschrauber das braucht man das
meinen ganz kleiner ersatz zonen kommen
und von dort dann weiter an so geht
ich habe heute ein paar sachen gehört
gesehen erlebt das hätte man gedacht
werd ich überlegte ruhige coole leute
perfekt ausgebildet wurde für jeden
einzelnen das grün hast du bist bei ihm
sicher und in der gruppe sowieso
also wenig
verwenden
oder sagen